hey guys thanks for tuning in today i'm
going to talk to you
about developing grip strength and
forearm strength with just body weight
training
so your grip strength is actually really
important for your
general physical development not only do
you use it obviously to hold the weights
that you're going to be curling and
pressing but if you're doing body weight
exercise
then you actually use your forearm
strength in order to balance a lot of
the time if you think about it your
whole weight is going straight through
your wrists
and all that is controlled by your
forearm if you want to increase your
bench press if you want to increase your
uh bicep curl if you want to be able to
do better handstands
then developing forearm and grip
strength is actually a really important
part of your training
which a lot of people forget and leave
out and this is particularly a problem
if you work out from home because it's
not that easy to train your grip
or your forearms when you've got no
weights or anything like that to use
normally if you're going to train your
forearms
using weights you would use mostly wrist
curls
wrist curls you would rest your arm on a
bench you'd hold the weight
and you do it that way and you do it
that way
you do have that option if you're
working out with body weight so you need
to get a little bit more inventive
and i'm going to show you how you do
that you might find that once you start
improving your grip strength but
actually your strength across the board
improves
will improve your martial arts as well
and just you'll be generally more
powerful so this is worth
investing a little bit of time in at the
end or the beginning of your bicep
workout that's where i put it so first
of all let's break down
uh what your grip strength and your form
strength is actually made of
where it comes from so you've got your
forearms obviously
and they control the movements of your
wrists
you have your forearm flexors which are
what make you do that
and you have your forearm extensors
which will make you do
that you can see so um
you have the forms there that pull you
that way and the muscles there
help you pull in that way this is what's
very important for doing handstands
because you're using those muscles to
stabilize your hand
you'll find often that when you give up
doing handstands
and fall the reason is your arm tilts
that way
and you topple over so you want to
increase the strength of those four
muscles to hold your arm
steady you also have your pronator
muscles and your supinator muscles
their job is to twist your arms there
and a pronated grip is one way your hand
is overhand supplemented
is underhand as you do for a curl
and the pronator is controlled by
something called the pronator terrace
i don't know why it's called that and
that twists your arm in that way
the suffinator is controlled by
something called uh the supinator muscle
which is a little
less imaginative and creative and that
turns your arm in that way so anything
where you're
twisting your body you obviously can't
do that
anything where you're twisting your arm
will engage those and that's one of the
reasons that the twisting
bicep curls where you go from a
underhand grip to a hammer grip
are so useful then on top of this you
have muscles i think one's called the
brachialis i'm cutting on the other one
and their job is to aid in the movement
of your elbow
going backwards and forwards these are
muscles in your
um forearms which basically support
the mechanism of your biceps and your
triceps so another good
important reason to work those out
because they'll help you to um
to strengthen your bicep curl and your
tricep kickbacks
etc then you also have the muscles in
your hand
as well as the flexors and extensors
which provide you with your grip
strength that's a combination of several
muscles
all kind of weaving over each other the
best way to
target those and to train your grip is
to just
you know use your grip so without
further ado
as you can imagine the um the wrist
curls i described earlier
for training the extensors and the
flexors
in the forearms which i just described
so what's the equivalent that you can do
with body weight well using a pull-up
bar
you can actually do something very
similar if you notice i'm only moving
my wrists barely this isn't the full
range of motion
it's not as good as a um
is a wrist curl but if it's all you've
got it's better than nothing and you can
do the same with both an underhand
and an overhand grip a slidier bar in
this scenario
would actually be beneficial because i'd
be able to slide my arm up more
and it worked quite well on the neutral
grip probably that's the best
but then you can only get the flexes
with that the neutral grip
allows me to bring the wrists up and
like that
you can feel it a little bit in the
forearms again it's not great
you could also add it to your regular
pull up
at the end just feel your forearms
engaged there
and put in a slight wrist flex at the
top
of each pull-up so that's one way of
training those the other
is just to do handstands do lots of them
because like i say you're going to be
using that to balance and if you try
going from a leaning tower handstand
which is where you're not a straight
line to a normal one if you try doing
things like
planche push-ups all these things you'll
be having your wrists at awkward angles
against the ground and as you do that
you will be engaging the forearms
to an extent speaking of press-ups by
the way
one of the best ways to make press-ups
harder on your forearms
and your fingers and hand strength is of
course to do it on your fingers
and if you're bruce lee you could do it
on one finger
or two fingers or three fingers that's a
good one although i find it's
quite achy i'm not sure if it's great if
you've got arthritis
um another really good one is to do the
superman press ups which are the ones
where your arms are extended right out
in front of you
um so that really that your arm is at
this angle
um when you're doing the press-ups and
as you can imagine that that requires a
lot of foreign strength to
keep that position stable another one is
the
la lan push-ups which is the same thing
but on your fingers
double hard check out my index of body
weight moves
both moves are described in more detail
on their
link in the description so the flex
that's how you
train the flexors and the extensors with
body weight it's not ideal
you can also obviously use
self-resistance
where you would be pushing against those
muscles
like so but remember training grip also
uses the extensors and reflectors to
degree
so you grab your towel there are many
ways you can train your grip
using body weight and a pull-up bar
one is simply
to hold on to something that's a little
that requires a bit more grip than a bar
such as this towel
so then there's i'm literally just
holding myself
up through my gripping strength
and you can feel that in your hand nice
thing about this
one nice thing the good thing about this
is that it also toughens up your grip
you can feel it on your hands and a lot
of the reason again
you often give up on movement sooner is
because your hands hurt
so i shouldn't be using gloves because
you'll never strengthen your grip that
way
if you want your strength to actually be
useful don't pull up from a tree by the
way
fantastic for grip and for
general um toughness of your hands
because you're holding on to this
big barky branch which
is quite difficult in that it's large
and that's another
useful thing uh if you can make the bar
larger
it's similar to some people use larger
barbells in the gym
in order to train their grip you can
similarly
do the same thing with the pull-up bar
if you can find a way to make it
thicker i mean that hasn't made a huge
difference but it's actually
forcing me to uh
use just the edges of my hands because i
can't quite grip onto it where normally
when the towel itself isn't that stable
so although it hasn't
worked perfectly it's still changing the
grip slightly
again if you think about the way you
trained naturally you know the pull-ups
we'd have done
in the wild would have been climbing
trees and you didn't have this one
uniform with the bar
you're always grabbing onto different
size things perhaps one of the best and
most
underrated exercises for strengthening
your grip though
is the good old hang where you simply
hang from above
and here i'm using an underhand grip
it's actually harder if you use an
overhand grip
like so and see how long you can hang if
you can hang for a couple of
minutes then you can consider yourself
very strong
but again you'll feel that that
stretches your
lats and it's generally quite
uncomfortable
but they say it's good for your back i'm
not so sure but yeah you can try it but
uh edo patel uh believes in
hanging a lot but yeah what you'll find
is that it's actually
your hands that start to give out first
as they start to slide so adding a hang
has a nice symmetric hold of sorts
the end of your workout is a good
strategy you can also
use a flex tang where you're at the top
of the movement
you'll find that this actually is less
difficult
on the grip itself but um because you're
just a slightly easier
angle more of a right angle it's just
straight down
trying to grip on but again it's uh it's
mixing up
it counts a lot so you've done a whole
bunch of
pull-ups to the point of failure then
why not just test your grip
but just hang in there for a minute or
two afterwards
another option of course is to hang
using just your fingers
like so and you can do curls whilst you
hang
and you can do pull ups whilst hanging
just from your fingers
and the further to the edge of your
fingers to go the more it will train
strengthen some of those muscles that
you also happen to use for crushing
things
that's actually um something that a lot
of rock climbers do in order to
increase their grip strength because
they have to grip onto these tiny little
um little bits on the wall
using just pure finger strength so
they'll do
pull ups from their fingers like so
using something called the fingerboard
which you can buy online relatively
cheaply
yeah rock climbs actually have amazing
forearms that they're huge as well as
lats
because they're pulling themselves all
the time everywhere like lat pull-downs
essentially um and one of the best
things you can do
using your body weight to improve your
forearm strength and your laptop and
also just for general uh
bodyweight training is to do rock
climbing if you have a rock climbing
club near you then i highly recommend
giving it a go
or you can always just rock climb in
your area
obviously you probably don't live near a
cliff face and i wouldn't recommend you
climbing up there without lots of
equipment and stuff
but what you can do is to do uh
traversing and that's where you don't
climb up the rock face
you climb along the rock base so you
grab onto the wall
and you just climb along just the only
rule is your feet can't touch the floor
invest in some climbing shoes if you
want to take them seriously they do make
a huge difference
or you can even just climb around the
bark at the um
in a park around the edge of a tree and
like all these things just require you
to grip onto the
wall like that and it's a fantastic
endurance task
and it's amazing for building your laps
and your forearm strength so
something else to consider is a very
unique way of adding to your training
again this still takes time it's not the
most fun thing in the world
but it's worth adding in if you don't
have dumbbells that you can use to
increase your grip or just every now and
then use a towel instead of
using the bark just keep it mixed up and
try to involve your grip
don't let your grip feel left out
because forearms they get lonely when
you're training all the other body parts
and it's fully it's pure folly to ignore
them because
you can't do anything that uses your
arms without going through your forearms
and through your grip finally the um
way that you might work the pronators
and supinators
is with body weight is you could try
using the perfect push-ups
those are those push-up stands that
twist as you go up and down
or um as i did in a previous video you
can try just
twisting your own hands as you do press
ups
if you put your hand on a cloth or if
you've got a shiny floor or just
man up and do it and again and again you
can do it by just doing a press up
like so but also trying all the
different angles
just so that you're training the
forearms in different ways
so there you go there's a whole bunch of
different ways you can train your
forearms and your grip
try and work them into your other
workouts and you'll notice that your
overall strength increases a lot
and when your overall strength increases
you can lift more weight and when you
lose more weight
then your muscle size increases so worth
doing
i hope this is helpful um let me know
you think in the comments and if you
enjoyed this video please subscribe and
i look forward to seeing you
in the next one bye for now